this character kevin has to be one of
the most complex you've ever played how
do you even begin
Kevin is is one guy but the eight other
people that I have to play they're all
little not complicated either well
they're all complicated I see
everybody's complicated but they're not
complicated any more than any other
character so I'm not playing Kevin and
he's complicated cause he's getting nine
people vying for space I'm just playing
nine different people I'm doing nine
times they might at work I usually do ya
know you have to make them breathe and
you have to make them live and you have
to make them your own I'm fascinated by
watching this film and I'm curious what
was the craziest thing you learned about
it doing research everything I talked
about in the movie is real whatever they
believe they are they are that's what's
so fascinating about is how much the
connection between the mind and body is
we have things in our society that we
take for granted like we get stressed
our blood pressure goes up we take that
for granted oh yeah you changed your
body because of you where you were
thinking and so continue that with the
edid to this incredible extent it's it's
fascinating what do you learn from M
night Shyamalan would you take away he
changed the way I acted forever well
I'll always remember it for the rest of
my life I was crying hysterically at one
point and night comes up to me and very
gently he's like your work is beautiful
what you're doing right now
but I've seen you cry like this don't be
selfish give the character her tears and
he opened up an entire world of acting
from empathy and it's so much easier to
feel things for other people than it is
to feel it for yourself let me ask you
if you could create a personality to
deal with the situation that you're
never comfortable in I think I always do
don't we all yes yes I agree
yes you have a professional personality
and you know then you have your your
good ol boy with the guy's personality
I'd bring up someone that was I guess a
bit less nervous I to some extent envied
this ability to compartmentalize in this
in this fashion because I am the
opposite of that like if I had a fight
with you and then I went into another
meeting I'd be like I could get it out
of my head the guy who can
in anger still remain calm and and like
chateau someone with the comment that
you always think of four hours later I'd
like that guy to come in the human brain
is the most complex object in the
universe
[Music]
you